cette semaine dans les salles de
l'espace philippe noiret de la ville les
clayes-sous-bois nous avons un avant
goût des vacances scolaires avec en
sortie nationale
la deuxième aventure de shaun le mouton
ou la ferme contre attaque
l'avant première du film abominable et
le fameux film culte de steven spielberg
ready playerone que nous vous proposons
en ciné débat le mardi 22 octobre à
16h30 dans le cadre de la semaine de la
parentalité
nous vous proposons également à lisser
le maire à mettant en scène fabrice
luccini et anis démons anaïs des montier
est également nous vous invitons de
venir voir le film donne moi des ailes
de nicolas vanier une aventure
palpitante et merveilleuse que vous fera
traverser les cieux et les mers du nord
en ulm aux côtés de jean paul rouve
mélanie doutey pluie wacquez et bien sûr
des oies sauvages
vous pourrez retrouver ce film la
semaine suivante en compagnie de joker
jay minimale ou terminator fine ou
encore angry birds